um as the name suggest in these problems
we have a number of variables and a
bunch of constraints on these variables
and uh the goal is to come up with an
assignment that uh satisfies most number
of uh constraints at the same time let's
uh stay concrete and work through an
example uh the example that I chose uh
um is uh the magic square puzzle um I'm
sure everyone in this room have seen one
form or another a magic square puzzle uh
here I'm going to tell you but my
favorite one um we have a 3X3 Square um
and uh the goal is to arrange uh the
numbers plus one minus one uh in this uh
in the cells of this Square such that a
number of constraints are satisfied the
constraints are that uh we want uh the
product of every row and column to be
plus one except for the last column
where we want the product to be minus
one okay U so this is a constant
satisfaction problems with nine
variables and six constraints and the
question is can we satisfy all of them
at the same time um a moment's thought
shows that no this is impossible and the
reason for it is that if I could um come
up with an assignment that satisfy all
the constraints then uh a row first
product of all the variables would yield
plus one uh whereas a column first uh
product of the variables would yield uh
a minus one and this is a contradiction
um so this is a very good uh
representative of uh classical con
satisfaction problems in quantum
computer science uh we study exactly the
same um problems con satisfaction
problems exactly this one for example
but uh the difference is that uh the
domain of the variables instead of being
a a discrete binary like here plus minus
one uh the domain of the variables in
the uh the quantum version of these
problems would be um a higher
dimensional generalization ations of
plus and minus one uh it turns out that
higher dimensional generalization of
plus minus one are unitary matrices plus
minus one themselves are special unitary
matrices and uh it turns out so so the
quantum magic square would be trying to
assign uh matrices unitary matrices to
the cells such that the product of the
rows and columns are plus minus uh
identity operators okay it turns out in
this more General domain uh there is a
solution that satisfy all the
constraints at the same time um the the
specifics of this U assignment doesn't
matter it's a you know these XY Zs are
famous matrices that show up all over
Quantum mechanic and their tensor
product would produce an the assignment
uh that satisfies all the constraints
again doesn't matter what they are but
just this mere fact that uh classically
magic square doesn't have a solution but
quantumly does
really uh lies at the heart of a lot of
applications of uh quantum computer
science um in cryptography in in
complexity Theory but the applications
go far beyond computer science in fact
magic square was proposed by physicist a
long a long time before Computer
Sciences had started thinking about
these problems and the goal they had in
mind was to design an experiment that um
that shows that uh nature uh behaves
according to the laws of quantum
mechanic rather than classical mechanic
um in fact um uh this this was the
experimental validation uh at the core
of which was uh a puzzle like magic
square uh was uh um the subject of the
Nobel Prize uh in physics last
year um so now that uh we uh we can tell
that these problems are important all
over the place uh let me tell you about
some of the things that we know about
them
uh un likee the example of magic square
which was very easy to reason about in
general Quantum csps are really really
hard much harder than classical
csbs but um there are very famous
examples like magic square there are
many others uh where finding the quantum
uh solution is actually easier sometimes
than the classical solution and we were
intrigued by this problem we wanted to
understand what are what are exactly
these these classes of problems in in in
um in a preprint that is currently under
with my coauthors we were able to show
that there is a class of of of of uh con
satisfaction problems technically known
as Max to Lin problems where this this
phenomenon occurs where where the
quantum solution can be found uh more
efficiently efficiently whereas
classically we don't know whether we
could do that or not um just one last
thing uh there are a lot of um open
problems uh in this kind of like line of
thinking uh one is the following uh
every classical solution is a Quantum
solution I told you plus minus one in
the magic square are unitary operators
right uh so given this kind of um
observation one could ask um if I am
given a Quantum solution could I could I
extract a good classical solution from
it I told you in the previous slide
there are some problems where we can
actually solve the quantum problem
easier so could could I extract a good
classical solution from a Quantum
solution and we have sub preliminary
result on this one that tells us that uh
there is a general algorithm that can
take any Quantum solution and extract a
good classical solution and it works in
uh on all those problems that I
mentioned in the last Slide the max to
problems okay um
and so far it only reproduces uh the
best classical the best known classical
algorithms but uh this is very
preliminary and we hope that we could go
beyond beyond what classical literature
can provide us all right that's all I
have
thanks a lot maybe we can prer questions
for the break
which thank you um so next we have